il ne faut pas confondre un vide château
et la vide château les deux ont quand
même ceci en commun un vide château
c'est la possibilité pour tout à chacun
de s'approprier un peu de ce qui fait la
vie de château les uns sont venus avec
une idée bien précise mais plus ou moins
raisonnable parfois quelque chose
d'impossible je pense mais qui a son
attrait une un fragment de clés de voûte
je pense que je ne pourrais pas avoir le
problème c'est que ça risquait de faire
s'effondrer le château et c'était pas le
but c'est d'ailleurs souvent pour
l'édifice que certains avaient fait le
déplacement on connaissait pas donc
voilà faire une petite visite en même
temps et puis puis voir s'il y a deux
trois trucs intéressants vous aimeriez
ramener
quoi je sais pas euh je sais pas un truc
qui qui va me qui va me plaire qui va je
sais pas et il y avait le choix des
milliers de pièces qui constituaient
tout le mobilier de l'hôtel restaurant
on a vu les tableaux bon les tableaux ça
va ça nous intéresse pas trop mais il y
a de la vaisselle a priori oui ça
devrait si sil a encore j'étais
intéressé aussi par la vaisselle mais
regardez cette affluence là c'est
incroyable moi j'ai jamais vu ça je
voulais emporter un souvenir du château
avant qu'il ne soit en travaux et j'ai
trouvé mon bonheur qu'est-ce que vous
avez trouvé des assiettes des assiettes
je voulais absolument qu'il ait la tête
de ser que les riverins se rassurent si
intérieur et extérieur vont changer le
château restera bien pièce maîtresse du
décor de Jito on a très joli projet pour
ce ce beau château on va on va essayer
de garder son histoire son caractère
historique et aujourd'hui on organise le
vide château parce que parce qu'une page
se tourne on s'attendait pas à une telle
affluence on est on est surpris du de ce
monde on savait qu'il y avait un
caractère historique qui qui plaît aux
locaux et on est conscient de de cette
oui de cette dimension de de de ça fait
partie du du territoire du patrimoine
bourguignon un spa une piscine un
restaurant bistronomique certes il va y
avoir du champ
château même si certains insensies à
toute cette agitation y conserveront
leurs petites
habitudes